.
Ich nehme dieses Video auf
am 1. April 2020.
In Deutschland werden 73.217
Corona-Fälle gezählt, 802 Tote.
Kitas, Schulen,
Geschäfte sind geschlossen,
soziale Kontakte
auf ein Minimum beschränkt.
Viele sind gerade
arbeitslos oder auftragslos,
während sich andere kaputt arbeiten,
um dieses Land am Laufen zu halten.
Bis nach Ostern
sind diese Maßnahmen noch angedacht.
Danach will man weiterschauen,
so heißt es momentan.
Wie lange kann man so einen
Ausnahmezustand schon durchhalten?
Wir brauchen noch etwas Ausdauer.
Noch ziemlich viel Ausdauer.
Solange wir keinen Impfstoff haben,
ist die Pandemie erst vorbei,
wenn sich 60-70 %
der Bevölkerung infiziert haben.
Bzw. wenn sich 60-70 %
infiziert haben, wieder erholt haben,
dann erst mal immun sind.
Dann haben wir "Herdenimmunität".
Also es sind genügend Menschen immun,
damit der Ausbruch
zum Erliegen kommt.
60-70 % sind in Deutschland
48-56 Mio. Menschen.
Rechnen wir mal schnell:
Wir haben in Deutschland
ungefähr 73.000 Fälle.
Nehmen wir mal an,
die Dunkelziffer sei 10-mal so hoch.
Also auf jeden Infizierten
kommen 9 nicht detektierte.
Dann hätten wir 730.000 Fälle.
730.000 von 48-56 Mio.
Also haben wir wahrscheinlich gerade
ein bisschen mehr
als 1 % Herdenimmunität.
Die Corona-Krise geht
also gerade erst richtig los.
Wie lange müssen wir
also noch durchhalten?
Als Antwort
hört man momentan vor allem:
"Das ist noch zu früh zu sagen."
"Abwarten, wie effektiv
unsere Maßnahmen sein werden."
"Schauen wir mal,
dann sehen wir ja."
Über ein paar Dinge sollten wir
jetzt schon ausführlich sprechen.
Und Zahlen anschauen, die man
vielleicht nicht sehen möchte.
Deswegen holt euch einen Tee,
macht es euch gemütlich.
Denn so viel vorweg:
Wir brauchen Geduld.
Eines vorweg: Es ist richtig,
dass wir gerade auf die Daten
über die Wirksamkeit
unserer aktuellen Maßnahmen warten.
Die haben wir erst in 2, 3 Wochen.
Darüber will ich
hier auch nicht spekulieren.
Es ist richtig und wichtig,
im Nebel auf Sicht zu fahren.
Aber wir wollen
doch trotzdem ungefähr wissen,
wie lange die Straße
sein wird, oder?
Über die Länge der Straße
wissen wir jetzt
schon ziemlich gut Bescheid.
Bei all der Berichterstattung über
die Corona-Krise ist das ein Punkt,
über den meiner Meinung nach
zu wenig diskutiert wird.
Um das alles zu verstehen,
kurz ein paar Basics
zu allgemeinen Epidemie-Maßnahmen:
Unter "Containment"
verstehen Epidemiologen Eindämmung.
Also idealerweise versucht man,
die Krankheit im Keim zu ersticken.
Zu solchen
Eindämmungs-Maßnahmen gehören:
Kranke isolieren,
Kontakte nachverfolgen, isolieren,
auf das Virus testen,
Überblick behalten
und die Verbreitung verhindern.
Es kann aber schnell so etwas
passieren wie z.B. in Heinsberg:
Ein infiziertes Paar
feiert mit 300 weiteren Karneval,
und dann kommt man
kaum mehr hinterher.
Irgendwann übersteigt
die Nachverfolgung der Kontakte
den Verwaltungsapparat.
Enter, Phase 2: "Mitigation".
Am besten zu übersetzen
mit Schadensbegrenzung.
Wenn wir nicht mehr nachvollziehen
können, wer alles infiziert ist,
klappt
die gezielte Isolierung nicht mehr.
Deswegen müssen wir alle mitmachen:
Abstand halten, Home Office,
Veranstaltungen absagen usw.
Ihr kennt das.
In dieser Phase hat man den Versuch
einer Eindämmung erst mal aufgegeben.
Aber man will jetzt wenigstens
die Ausbreitung verlangsamen.
Warum das so wichtig ist,
dürfte bei jedem angekommen sein.
Über #flattenthecurve
wurde so viel gesprochen,
dass das Grundprinzip von Mitigation
den meisten klar sein sollte.
Aber dieses
rein qualitative Verständnis
kann trügerisch wirken.
Noch mal kurze Wiederholung:
Je langsamer die Epidemie verläuft,
desto weniger Menschen
sind gleichzeitig infiziert
und desto weniger Menschen brauchen
gleichzeitig medizinische Behandlung.
So verhindern wir, dass unser
Gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht,
was wir leider gerade
in Italien, Spanien oder New York
mit Schrecken beobachten.
Wenn die Intensivstation
nicht mehr genügend Betten
für alle Patienten haben,
müssen schreckliche Entscheidungen
über Leben und Tod getroffen werden.
Das darf nicht passieren.
Das Problem ist, dass bei vielen
folgender Eindruck entsteht:
Der Lockdown ist heftig,
aber wir geben alles.
Hoffentlich kriegen wir
damit die Kurve so flach,
dass wir vielleicht nach Ostern,
vielleicht ein bisschen später
das Ganze einigermaßen glimpflich
hinter uns gebracht haben.
Diese Vorstellung
ist leider realitätsferne Fantasie.
Das verstehen wir, wenn wir
uns konkrete Zahlen anschauen.
Fangen wir
an mit einer zentralen Größe:
Die Basisreproduktionszahl
R0 gibt an,
wie viele Menschen eine infizierte
Person im Durchschnitt ansteckt.
Wenn niemand immun ist und wenn
keine Maßnahmen getroffen werden.
Für das Sars-CoV-2
wird R0 derzeit auf 2-3 geschätzt.
Jeder Infizierte
steckt im Schnitt 2-3 weitere an.
Wenn die Reproduktionszahl
auf unter 1 fällt,
jeder Infizierte im Schnitt weniger
als eine weitere Person ansteckt,
dann kommt der Ausbruch
zum Erliegen.
Alle Maßnahmen der letzten Wochen,
vom Aufruf zum Händewaschen über
Kontaktverfolgung bis zum Lockdown,
dienen dazu,
die Reproduktionszahl zu senken.
Wir sprechen dann von
der effektiven Reproduktionszahl.
Grafisch gesprochen:
je kleiner die Reproduktionszahl,
desto flacher die Kurve.
Diese Frage wird beantwortet
in der Stellungnahme der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für Epidemiologie
zur Ausbreitung
des neuen Coronavirus.
Hier findet man Modellierungen
für verschiedene Szenarien.
Diese Modellierungen
sind wohl gemerkt keine Voraussagen.
Jede Epidemie ist ein Einzelfall.
Deswegen arbeiten ja gerade
auch Forscher mit Hochdruck daran,
dieses neue Virus
besser zu verstehen.
Modellierungen können verschiedene
denkbare Szenarien durchrechnen,
in deren Rahmen sich der
zukünftige Verlauf bewegen könnte.
Anhand dieser Szenarien
können wir ableiten,
welche Maßnahmen den Verlauf
in welcher Form beeinflussen können.
Wie würde nun
die effektive Reproduktionszahl
den Verlauf beeinflussen?
Oder konkreter gesagt:
Also so flach, dass unser
Gesundheitssystem es handlen kann.
Dazu brauchen wir
eine Vorstellung davon,
wie groß die Kapazitäten unseres
deutschen Gesundheitssystems sind.
Dazu gehört natürlich vieles:
Beatmungsgeräte, Schutzkleidung
fürs Personal, das Personal an sich.
Aber nehmen wir mal
einen limitierenden Faktor,
mit dem wir das Ganze
durchrechnen können:
die Anzahl der Betten
auf den Intensivstationen,
auf die die schweren
Corona-Verläufe angewiesen sind.
In Deutschland gibt es derzeit rund
30.000 intensivmedizinische Betten.
Die sind aber nicht alle frei.
Bei allen laufenden Bemühungen,
die Kapazitäten aufzustocken,
sind viele dieser Betten besetzt
von Nicht-Corona-Patienten.
Aber nehmen wir
für unsere Betrachtung an,
wir hätten 30.000 freie Betten.
Wie viele Menschen
werden jetzt wegen COVID-19
ein Bett
auf einer Intensivstation brauchen?
Und wie lange
muss man sie dort behandeln?
Die Deutsche Gesellschaft
für Epidemiologie schätzt,
dass 2-6 % der Corona-Infizierten
ein Intensivbett brauchen.
Die Liegedauer ist relativ lang,
nämlich 10-20 Tage,
je nach Patient.
Hier wurden jetzt
9 verschiedene Szenarien modelliert.
Mit 2, 4 oder 6 %
intensivpflichtigen Patienten
und mit 10, 15
oder 20 Tagen Liegedauer.
Schauen wir uns zuerst
das Best-Case-Szenario an,
in dem nur 2 % der Erkrankten
eine Intensivbehandlung brauchen
und zwar alle nur für 10 Tage.
In diesem Szenario würde man
bei einer Reproduktionszahl von 1,5,
das ist die grüne Kurve,
die Kapazitäten über einen
langen Zeitraum komplett sprengen.
Erst bei
einer Reproduktionszahl von 1,25
nähern wir uns
zwar der 30.000 Betten-Grenze,
würden sie zu Peak-Zeiten
aber immer noch sprengen.
Und wenn es jetzt 4 % sind,
sind es doppelt so viele Patienten,
die ein Bett brauchen.
Bei den meisten dieser Szenarien
muss die Reproduktionszahl
auf 1,1 oder sehr nah
an 1,1 runtergedrückt werden,
um eine Überbelastung
der Intensivstationen zu vermeiden.
Im Worst-Case-Szenario haben wir
selbst bei einer Reproduktionszahl
von 1,1 zu Peak-Zeiten
zehntausende Menschen täglich,
die nicht behandelt werden können.
Das ist nur mit ordentlicher
Kontaktreduktion möglich.
Jetzt schaut mal auf die Zeitachse.
Bei diesen strengen Maßnahmen
wäre die Epidemie
erst nach einem Jahr vorbei.
In den meisten Fällen noch länger.
Die flachste Kurve, die dunkelblaue,
die ist abgeschnitten!
Wir gehen hier Richtung 2 Jahre.
Und das ... geht nicht.
Wir sehen ja jetzt schon,
welche immensen Schäden für die
Volkswirtschaft zu erwarten sind.
Da hängen Existenzen
und damit auch Menschenleben dran.
Und auch, welche
allgemeinen gesellschaftlichen,
auch psychologischen Folgen
das langfristig hätte.
Das können wir derzeit
noch gar nicht fassen.
Ich weiß, dass bei diesen
Modellierungen nicht nur Annahmen,
sondern
auf Vereinfachungen gemacht wurden.
Ich weiß, dass es
noch Parameter über COVID-19 gibt,
die wir noch nicht kennen,
die aber
einen wesentlichen Einfluss haben.
Wie z.B., was mit den sehr schwachen
oder asymptomatischen Verläufen ist.
Aber allein diese Größenordnung.
Wenn die Größenordnung
nicht völlig daneben ist,
dann ist #flattenthecurve bis zur
Herdenimmunität nicht durchhaltbar.
Nun ist
diese Stellungnahme nicht brandneu.
Also sie wurde am Tag
von Merkels Ansprache veröffentlicht
und ein paar Tage
später aktualisiert.
Wenn ich heute
in die Medienberichte schaue,
wird immer noch
der Eindruck vermittelt,
als sei #flattenthecurve
immer noch der Masterplan.
Wie kann das sein, wenn das
offenbar so nicht aufgehen wird?
Ich habe auch mit
Prof. Rafael Mikolajczyk geredet,
der diese Stellungnahme mitverfasst
hat, um mich zu versichern,
dass wir nicht etwas Grundlegendes
missverstanden haben.
Vielen Dank für das
aufschlussreiche Hintergrundgespräch.
Die Ergebnisse
sind nicht anders zu interpretieren.
Die Antwort auf die Frage:
Sie lautet: die Reproduktionszahl
muss auf unter 1 gesenkt werden.
Denn Abflachen alleine
würde zu lange dauern.
Wir müssen die Kurve stoppen.
Die Fallzahl muss so klein werden,
dass unsere Gesundheitsämter
wieder dazu in der Lage sind,
alle Fälle
zu überschauen und zu verfolgen.
Dann können wir wieder
effektiv Kranke isolieren,
Kontakte verfolgen, Kontaktketten
brechen, die Krankheit eindämmen.
Das bedeutet,
wenn die Infektionszahlen
nicht mehr nur langsamer steigen,
sondern wirklich abnehmen,
dann kommen wir irgendwann
wieder zu einem Punkt,
wo wir mit unseren Maßnahmen wieder
bei Phase 1 "Containment" sind.
Und dann ...
Dann würde für viele Menschen wieder
so etwas wie Normalität zurückkehren.
Denn dann
wären die strengen Maßnahmen
wieder nur gezielt auf die Erkrankten
und
ihre Kontaktpersonen konzentriert.
Nur ist der Weg zurück zu Phase 1
natürlich nur mit
strengen Maßnahmen für alle machbar.
Denn noch mal:
Ein Infizierter muss weniger
als einen weiteren anstecken,
damit das aufgeht.
Wie schnell
hat man 2 Personen angesteckt?
Vor allem, wenn man nicht darauf
achten, weil man milde Symptome hat?
Oder wenn irgendwo
jemand 10 weitere Menschen ansteckt
bei irgendeiner Veranstaltung,
dann dürfen 9 andere
niemanden mehr anstecken.
Reichen denn nun
unsere aktuellen Maßnahmen aus,
um die Reproduktionszahl
so stark zu senken?
Auf diese Einschätzung
warten wir gerade.
Aber so viel
kann man schon mal sagen:
Dass dieser Lockdown
beschlossen wurde,
ist definitiv angemessen und richtig.
Also wenn wir wirklich
zu Phase 1 zurückwollen,
ist das, was wir gerade machen,
auf keinen Fall übertrieben
oder unnötig streng.
Denn wir können jetzt schon sagen,
dass wir noch weit entfernt sind
von einer Fallzahl, die niedrig
genug ist. Denken wir das mal durch:
Im Netz gibt es einige
Online-Simulationen von Epidemien,
mit denen man rumspielen kann.
Jetzt mal nur zur Veranschaulichung,
der ist ganz gut.
Wir können jetzt die Parameter,
so was wie Ansteckung,
Hospitalisierungs-Rate usw.
so einstellen, wie die Deutsche
Gesellschaft für Epidemiologie
in ihren Simulationen
gemacht hat.
Und dann schauen,
wie lange es dauern wird,
bis wir wieder
zu Containment übergehen können.
Jetzt muss ich eine Annahme treffen,
nämlich,
wie tief die Fallzahl sinken muss,
also ab welcher Fallzahl
Containment wieder möglich wäre.
Die wirkliche Zahl hängt z.B.
stark ab von unseren Testkapazitäten,
davon, wie viel Ressourcen
und Personal wir noch
in die Behörden stecken können,
wie gut die Infrastruktur ist usw.
Aber orientieren wir uns an dem Tag,
an dem Jens Spahn sagte,
dass man Veranstaltungen mit mehr
als 1000 Menschen absagen sollte.
Spätestens dann gab
es offenbar ein Problem
mit der Nachverfolgung der Fälle.
An diesem Tag gab es
in Deutschland ungefähr 1000 Fälle.
Nehmen wir an, 1000 wäre jetzt die
Fallzahl, die noch handlebar wäre,
ohne drastische Social-Distancing-
Maßnahmen für alle.
Jetzt haben wir heute
ca. 70.000 Fälle.
Jetzt können wir einstellen,
dass wir ab dem Tag,
wo die Epidemie 70.000 Fälle hat,
die Reproduktionszahl
von 2 auf 0,5 runterdrücken.
Reproduktionszahl 0,5,
das ist volle Kanone,
das ist Wuhan-style Lockdown,
so muss man sich das vorstellen.
Unter diesen Annahmen
würde es 56 Tage dauern,
bis wir wieder
weniger als 1000 Fälle hätten.
Also fast 2 Monate.
Das sollte jetzt
natürlich keine Prognose sein,
sondern nur ein Beispiel-Szenario,
um ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen,
wie lange das noch dauern könnte.
Nur, damit das
niemand falsch versteht:
Wenn wir es schaffen,
mit harten Maßnahmen
zurück zu Phase 1 zu kommen,
ist damit ja die Epidemie
noch nicht vorbei.
Wir kommen damit
lediglich in einen Zustand,
in dem sowohl unser Gesundheitssystem
als auch unsere Wirtschaft
funktionieren können.
Also in einen Zustand,
in dem wir so lange ausharren können,
bis die Epidemie vorbei ist.
Kleiner Einschub: Es gibt ein paar
unbekannte Eigenschaften des Virus,
die uns vielleicht
schneller ans Ziel bringen könnten.
Z.B. eine Saisonalität.
Das heißt, dass das Virus im Sommer
weniger ansteckend sein könnte.
Oder dass doch
ein Teil der Bevölkerung
eine gewisse Immunität
gegen dieses Virus haben könnte.
Dazu gibt es Modellierungen
vom Robert-Koch-Institut.
Die haben wir mit einer Einordnung
in die Videobeschreibung gepackt.
Aber an der Strategie an sich
würde das auch nichts ändern.
Es wäre falsch, aus
einer unbestätigten Hoffnung heraus,
Maßnahmen zu lockern.
Denn so oder so gilt:
Je schneller wir in Phase 1
zurück sind, desto besser.
Das klingt jetzt
nach ganz schön harter Arbeit,
nur um dahin wieder zurückzukommen,
wo wir schon vor einem Monat waren.
Aber ganz wichtig:
Wir gehen nicht
einfach nur einen Schritt zurück.
Die Containment-Phase
am Anfang einer Epidemie
steht unter folgenden Dilemma:
Je früher man Maßnahmen ergreift,
desto effektiver ist es.
Aber da eine Epidemie
anfangs nicht so schlimm ist,
wird die Bedrohung
oft zu spät erkannt.
Auch hierzulande wurde Corona von
vielen Menschen nicht ernst genommen.
Und politische Entscheidungsträger
sind ja nur das eine.
Auch ohne Akzeptanz
in der Bevölkerung
kann man strenge Maßnahmen
wie jetzt z.B. Karneval absagen
in einer Demokratie kaum durchsetzen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt wieder
zurück ins Containment kommen,
wissen wir, wie der Hase läuft.
Wir sind inzwischen auch
alle Profis im Händewaschen
und in den Ellbogen husten
und Abstand halten
und basteln sogar
an zusätzlichen Maßnahmen
wie selbstgenähte Gesichtsmasken.
Auch unser Gesundheitssystem und
die Forschung sind deutlich weiter.
Gerade
werden Testkapazitäten hochgefahren.
Die Behörden werden
mit mehr Manpower ausgestattet usw.
Nicht falsch verstehen.
Ich finde, Deutschland hat vernünftig
auf die Corona-Krise reagiert.
Aber wenn wir jetzt Phase 1
noch mal wiederholen würden,
würden wir
an allen möglichen Ecken und Enden
die Sache deutlich besser machen.
Weil wir jetzt vieles wissen,
was wir vorher nicht wussten.
Nur sollten wir uns klarmachen:
Wir arbeiten
auf eine Lockerung der Maßnahmen
und einen Rückgewinn
von Normalität hin.
Aber ganz ohne Verzicht werden
wir lange Zeit nicht auskommen.
Dazu gehört:
vermeidbare Menschenansammlungen.
Also Konzerte,
gefüllte Fußballstadien,
dicht gepackte Rhein-Strände,
Konferenzen ...
Dieses Jahr? Vergesst es.
Das wäre auch in
der Containment-Phase zu riskant.
Mit nur einem Ausbruch
könnten wir unsere
ganzen Bemühungen kaputtmachen.
Selbst Apres-Ski
im kommenden Winter ...
Dafür sehe ich schwarz,
denn eine Timeline habe ich noch.
Im Prinzip habe ich
das am Anfang schon gesagt:
Natürlicherweise
ist die Epidemie erst dann vorbei,
wenn Herdenimmunität erreicht ist,
aber das ist nur Theorie.
In der Praxis können wir
natürliche Herdenimmunität
quasi vergessen.
Es gibt kein Szenario,
bei dem wir eine Herdenimmunität
von 60-70 % erreichen könnten,
ohne dass dabei
unvorstellbare Schäden entstehen.
Entweder würden wir die Kapazität
unseres Gesundheitssystems sprengen,
dabei würden erschreckend
viele Menschen sterben.
Oder wir würden diese Herdenimmunität
unterhalb der Kapazität
unseres Gesundheitssystems verfolgen.
Aber das würde so lange dauern,
dass es wirtschaftlich
und gesellschaftlich
nicht ertragbar wäre.
Daraus kann ich nur eins schließen:
Diese Epidemie
wird erst mit einem Impfstoff enden.
Theoretisch auch
mit einem Medikament,
das aber auch die Intensivbehandlung
weitgehend ersetzen müsste,
was unwahrscheinlich ist.
Bis zum Impfstoff
müssen wir also durchhalten.
Die Entwicklung braucht Zeit.
Sportliche Schätzungen
sprechen hier von Frühjahr 2021.
Damit wir das so lange mit
möglichst wenig Schäden durchhalten,
müssen wir jetzt mit harten Maßnahmen
möglichst schnell zurück
zum Containment-Modus,
indem wir dann bei relativer
Normalität ausharren können.
Ich weiß, dass vieles in diesem Video
euch wahrscheinlich entmutigt hat.
Ich sehe das so: Ich habe lieber
einen konkreten Ausweg vor Augen,
auch wenn er schwer ist,
als immer nur
mit "wir müssen mal schauen"
im Ungewissen gehalten zu werden.
Wenn wir das Ziel kennen,
können wir besser zielen.
Wir können jetzt schon weitere
Hilfsmaßnahmen in die Wege leiten,
Oder Home-Office-Strukturen,
wo denn möglich, weiter ausbauen
und uns jetzt
schon mal Gedanken machen,
wie wir irgendwie länger durchhalten.
Es ist ein Marathon.
Aber ich kann auch nicht verstehen,
wie Menschen 42 km laufen können,
und trotzdem schaffen sie es.
Freunde der Sonne
lasst euch nicht unterkriegen.
Wenn ihr motivierenden Gedanken,
Ideen zur Ausdauer habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid gesund
und schlagt euch tapfer
durch diese unwirkliche Zeit.
Mir gehts gut, das Baby ist da.
Es ist ein sehr, sehr
süßes Freundchen in der Sonne.
Und wir sind zum Glück alle gesund.
Aber mein Herz geht raus an alle,
die von COVID-19 getroffen sind,
entweder selbst oder
im Freundes- oder Familienkreis.
An alle, die sich
gerade den Hintern aufreißen,
um diesen Laden am Laufen zu halten,
die sich um unsere Gesundheit
kümmern, um unsere Grundversorgung.
Und auch an alle,
die gerade nicht arbeiten können
oder nicht bezahlt werden.
Es ist eine verdammt heftige Zeit.
Zum Glück kann ich wenigstens
Mailab von zu Hause aus produzieren.
Auch wenn wir im Team
gerade etwas langsamer vorankommen,
weil sowohl Lars als auch Melanie
ein Kita-Kind zu Hause haben.
Deswegen hat es Melanie
auch nicht geschafft,
für diese Folge Grafiken zu machen.
Vielleicht habt ihr es gemerkt, sie
hat ein neues Kanal-Design erstellt,
das ich sehr cool finde.
Wir hoffen, es gefällt euch.
Natürlich ist das Social-Distancing,
die Abschottung
auch psychologisch echt nicht ohne.
Wenn es euch auch so geht,
kann ich euch das Video von
meiner lieben Kollegin Pia empfehlen.
Pia hat einen ganz neuen Funk-Kanal
aufgemacht: psychologeek.
Schaut da gerne mal vorbei, lasst
ein paar Grüße aka. Kekse von mir da.
Und jetzt endlich auch hiermit:
ein verspätetes,
aber umso fetteres Dankeschön
für euren tollen Support.
Danke für die vielen super lieben
Kommentare unter dem letzten Video.
Die haben mich sehr bewegt.
Sie haben es einerseits leicht,
aber auch wieder schwer gemacht,
in die Pause zu gehen.
Danke für alle,
die mir während der Pause,
also in den letzten Monaten
geschrieben haben.
Ich hab das mit
einem halben Auge mitbekommen,
denn ich habe nicht
nur YouTube-Pause gemacht,
sondern auch Social-Media-
und E-Mail-Pause.
Aber ich freue mich jetzt,
wieder zurück zu sein,
auch auf Instagram und Twitter.
Teilt das Video mit jedem,
den es interessieren könnte.
Erzählt euren Freunden,
dass Mailab back ist.
Es gibt ab jetzt
jeden 2. Donnerstag ein neues Video.
Deswegen sehen wir uns in 2 Wochen.
Bis dahin, es hat noch nie so sehr
gepasst wie jetzt: bleibt sicher.